does romance is
like lust you know when it's new and
it's
fresh i think the key to find somebody
in your life that you go this is my best
friend
is so
amazing
and so and you don't lose that and if
you could
learn to really cherish that that is the
the lust that becomes somebody who just
gets you and wants to be there with you
and that's the first person that you
want to share something with and that's
the first person and i mean share
good things to share equally to share
all the bad things
that is very uncommon in life to find
somebody like that
don't you think that that's normal too
after you've been with someone for so
long i i mean i've been with my husband
for
the same amount of time too
i think you do
lose that romance that you had at the
very very beginning but i think that
that's normal right isn't that normal
for every single relationship i think if
you're if you're pining for that feeling
then that is a problem
um i think well with us it's a it's a
different
our love languages are i've never been
aligned like he's somebody who is not he
does not like physical touch he has i'm
with him right and i understand it
because you know when he was younger um
that's not how he was shown love like he
was either beat
or he was either it wasn't touched in
like or molested inappropriately so like
his idea of touch comes with a oh his
like fight or flight is like he just
doesn't like to be touched he doesn't
like massages like you right um no but i
get that and i understand like i've
never really walked with my what ever
even in last walk with my wife holding
hands i would never really
never yeah and i'm in full acceptance of
that but then i'm also in a place now
where i'm like
but i i like cuddling yeah oh no
i hate cuddling yeah yeah i wanna so
boring well it's not only boring it's
it's claustrophobic yeah yeah you know
yeah and that doesn't mean i don't like
intimacy i like intimacy you know how do
you show intimacy did you ever take the
love language how do i show intimacy
she's sitting right here
the the result of intimacy oh right
right yeah did you ever take the love
language test ed i don't know the love
language so there's words of affirmation
there's physical touch there's quality
time acts of service acts of service and
gift giving the [ __ ] are you guys
talking about it i know i don't know
that's yeah yeah it's how you should
break it down break it down so what's
the first one
um let's start with physical touch
obviously so howie and i are out you're
out and i'm out too my husband that's
his highest one that was my lowest one
so that's where him and i are yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're on opposite spectrum
physical physical touch okay okay what's
the second one um let's go with words of
affirmation
you look beautiful you're very good at
words of affirmation he is so giving
with his words i'm the king of are you
good at words of affirmation i think i
am yes yeah i think i think you are too
i think i am too but that's my
bobby and i that's our tool is is uh
verbal whether it's comedy whether it's
communication whether it's
um but that's not your love language you
don't look for that you you don't look
for
um you're good at the information you're
good at giving them but how do you like
bobby
i'm so [ __ ] noisy in my head i don't
need you to tell me anything please i
can guess what you're like
i just want my [ __ ] space yeah stand
back stand back right yeah yeah so
that's you don't care if someone gives
you words of affirmation i only want
laughter okay yeah yeah
by people that don't matter it bothers
me more you know i i always use this
analogy
but but this is the analogy every comic
has this you will be in a room and
5 000 people will be roaring and loving
you and you look at one person you don't
know them you look at one person in the
front row that is like
looking at you with disgust not paying
attention and then it it becomes about
just grounding them and i know that
bobby is similar because
uh bobby
last year or two years ago was at the uh
two years ago was that just for last
festival and i went to see his show
and he remembers
that was a [ __ ] killer night and he
rocked the place and and everybody said
oh my god the bobby lee show was one of
the best shows i went we go to a bar
after where all the comics they said it
was one of the best shows after he will
still tell me the story about what some
guy yelled out in the middle of the show
and it's he goes next let's see that was
it but he remembers that one word like
the whole the whole
his whole world revolves around that one
and i kind of understand that but that's
not the perspective that everybody
okay so it's not words of affirmation
but it could be some version of that the
third one is acts of service when
someone does things for you he mitered
the [ __ ] bed right that is
but it's so you know even though you're
saying and i'm not i'm not knocking you
for this but this is what people don't
understand
it is so against our nature to do that
exactly no let me finish
now you're interrupting me
it is so against our nature so the fact
that he made that bed is so out of
character and so
he pushed himself so much forward even
if he leaves the uh the the shells of
the i agree
okay but what you have to do is you have
to see that without
the shells without the shell
okay i'll get there i'll get it no no no
but you don't have to but what i'm
saying is you got to know it's kind of
like and you don't have children i have
children
no but it's kind of like that you love
your child unconditionally if my kid
can't say if my kid can't say i love you
at two months old because they can't
talk you have to be cognizant of what
they have to offer what's in their
wheelhouse what's in their wheelhouse if
the kid at two months old can't talk
can't even really make eye contact you
still feel that same love and and
dependency
you know what i mean right so think of
bobby and me like infants
[Laughter]
but if her love language is physical
touch then that's what she's looking for
then maybe she doesn't even though she
accepts it and appreciates it like
that's not what she's looking for is the
bed made she's not looking for acts of
service she's looking for physical touch
right but i think in this life
no in this life you got to take what you
get and find a way to cope with that you
know life is about coping skills
and how do you cope with uh you know you
may go like i'm not getting this i'm not
getting this and i'm not getting this
what are you getting why don't you
create a robotic arm that can be your
proxy for when you don't want to like
get like cuddle like get me like a blow
up doll or something you can operate
from afar i spent you'd be okay with a
like a robot or an inflatable yeah you'd
be okay with an inflatable anything
that's amazing bobby by
something a hot inflatable
so she for the last 10 years
every night
give me foot rubs
i don't
you want massages all the time come
please please let's not fight
all right that's not you want foot rubs
all the time in fact when her mom comes
over to clean the house right can i say
that or no you can she helps the kid she
helps cleanse the house right um she
demands her mom to massage her feet for
an hour right oh so it's not even a
romantic thing yeah yeah so it's you or
her mom yeah so what i did anybody else
i bought it's uh coming in the mail i
bought a a very expensive foot massager
where you stick your feet in well you
know what i feel bad you've been here
like for an hour uh
kyle
you want to rub her feet
so anyway is that okay if kyle comes in
and rubbing your feet i don't know why i
went over caroline let's go back to the
love language okay let's go i want to
get to all of them so that was so that's
number three was um
so there's been done three acts of
service
you guys don't like words of affirmation
what we don't need them you don't need
them what about wait isn't laughter i
think you do need them because i know
that you look at like reviews you never
tell her she's beautiful all the time
she's he's really good at that also but
that's words of affirmation is not my
number one your number thing is number
one is touch touches might know yeah but
yeah but you happen to
and excuse me for being so forward and
if you want me to edit this line out
you you happen to partner with somebody
that was molested as a child and was
beaten so for you to need that and have
that at the top of your is that okay
that i said that i love it but also
howie i no but i'm saying if the number
one thing you need is to be touched you
partnered with somebody that was the
only touching they ever had was in a
[ __ ] hole though but him and i have
that in common so i was also beaten and
molested and assaulted most of my life
that's one of the one things we have in
common well i'm not saying that's the
normal reaction so you want but when we
first met
because he was just so in the mindset of
i'll do anything for kalila to be my
partner he pretended that physical touch
was one of the things he enjoyed so he
would cuddle me for years for for the
first two years i was a cuddle he was a
cuddler he
but everybody does that you know no no
nobody i'm on a show called [ __ ] on
netflix and i i love the show because
the [ __ ] is how we live
no first date no first month no first
year is the real person you you are in a
marriage now for 10 years i'm talking to
my daughter here you guys are in a
relationship for 10 years this is real
yeah nothing it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] i believe that [ __ ] is the
fuel of every relationship for the first
five years it's all [ __ ] [ __ ] it
is nobody is being nobody shows up their
true self right nobody right
you know and even our what we do for a
living you know we're not always silly
funny people
you know it's [ __ ] that comic that
you see on stage is [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]